de son appartement ils n'emportaient que
les clés frédéric a tout laissé chez lui
pour profiter du grand air profiter du
grand air au camping chez gg un repas
dehors en plein air sous le soleil le
bonheur quelqu'un de moi en retraite
vous soyez des retraites ce que c'était
dans le bâtiment voilà ça permet quand
même de s'évader un petit peu et plus de
profiter de deux gérard dit gg l'homme
au grand coeur qui est ouverte ce
terrain il ya une dizaine d'années à
deux pas du massif des vosges en haute
saône pour tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas
partir en vacances un endroit pas cher
ou convivialité bonne humeur sont au
rendez vous alors oui effectivement il
ya eu des galères l'an dernier des
soucis à rectifier puis la mort du
taulier celui qu'ils l'avaient aidé dans
ses choix dans sa vie qu'il est toujours
johnny pu mais un des derniers à avoir
un autographe signée de sa main
voilà sur son lit en plus pour moi c'est
important et à mes étudiants continuer
dans ce que tu fais rien voilà tient le
glas mon salaire ces gens auraient pas
pu partir en week-end en vacances coucou
coucou c'est moi
steve lui est arrivé hier avec sa femme
et ses enfants une heure de route
une caravane à disposition aménagé à
l'arrivée ces salles accueillent chez gg
un dépaysement total et surtout de
l'amitié tout le monde se retrouve
personnes se connaît à la sortie tout le
monde se connaît ça c'est vraiment sympa
après les puristes ce qu'ils vont aimer
vraiment cette ambiance là ici ils vont
être servis
mais dans le bon sens gégé a réouvert
une nouvelle saison jusqu'au 31 octobre
40 emplacements 5 euros la nuit
gratuit pour les enfants des prix minis
comme il le dit pour des vacances maxi